نجوم الكره يتفاعلون مع وفاه المعلق
الاسطوري هاملتون يتجسس على سياره فيرسب
تسريب زي ارسنال الخاص بالموسم المقبل هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
تفاعل النجوم كره القدم الانجليزيه
السابقين مع وفاه المعلق الاسطوري جون
وغرض كل من
والعديد من اللاعبين الاخرين عبر حساباتهم
لنعيم جون الذي علق على اكثر من 2000
مباراه وكان حاضرا في عشر نسخا من كاس
العالم والعديد من المباريات المميزه وهذا
على مدار اكثر من 50 عاما
قبل نحو ثلاثه اشهر من انتهاء الموسم
الكروي سرب زي ارسنال الجديد الخاص
بالموسم المقبل وكنزي الاساسي باللون
الاحمر المعتاد بينما كانت زي الاحتياطي
باللون الاصفر جماهير الفريق الانجليزي
تفاعلت مع هذا التسريب الذي لم يعجب شريحه
كبيره من المشجعين حيث قال البعض منهم بان
ارتداء هذا الزي هو امر محرج فيما تمنى
اخرون ان تبقى هذه التسريبات مجرد اشاعات
كاذبه
اختارها
خاصه لبدء موسم ببطوله العالم بعدين
استهلا جوله التجريبيه من جائزه البحرين
الكبرى بالتجسس على سياره منافسه حيث
التقطت صور لها متون وهو يلقي نظره عن قرب
على سياره الفريق ريد بول التي هزمته في
اخر عامين هذا الامر ليس جديدا على
النجمين فقد كان هو المتجسس في العام
الماضي وتعرض وقتها لغرامه ماليه
[موسيقى]